elle était connue comme les polars la
plus seule au monde qui scale alors que
vedette du parc marinel dans l'Ontario
vivait en captivité depuis plus d'une
quarantaine d'années elle aurait été
capturée dans les eaux islandaises avec
le célèbre épaulard du film mon ami
Willy mais elle vivait complètement seul
depuis plus d'une dizaine d'années selon
cette ancienne entraîneur du parc et
lanceur d'alerte
à toute leur vie avec la famille dans
les océans donc pour elle pour être
complément seul c'était comme
c'est de la souffrance que on peut pas
vraiment
comprendre
cette militante
depuis 2019 le Canada interdit de
maintenir en captivité de grands
mammifères marins et les utiliser à des
fins de divertissement à moins que le
spectacle ne soit autorisé par le
gouvernement de l'Ontario les deux
établissements qui en possédait déjà ont
toutefois pu les garder en raison d'une
clause de droits acquis aussi
7 militante affirme toutefois que les
lois en place ne sont souvent pas
respectées et qui les difficiles de
poursuivre les contenants en 2021 marin
land a été inculpé au pénal après que
l'organisme annemonde justice a déposé
une plainte allégant que les dauphins
étaient forcés de se produire en
spectacle mais les accusations ont été
suspendues en décembre 2022 le
propriétaire de Marinland a refusé notre
demande d'entrevue
cette expert compare la situation Americ
land a une histoire d'horreur et
rappelle que de nombreux c'est assez
sont toujours en captivité au Canada
le premier sanctuaire pour baleine en
Amérique du Nord est présentement en
construction au large de la
Nouvelle-Écosse rave de paix pour les
animaux ou qui scannera malheureusement
jamais eu la chance de se reposer il
Sandra nous lionne au Canada Tor